I've mentioned in a couple of lives now
that I've got a source that has told me
that the strikes will not delay this
planned Stargate movie or RoboCop or
Legally Blonde 3 more importantly
but how is that possible well I've just
had another conversation and it seems we
now know
welcome to side tracker Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so I'm just doing a quick video it's not
going to be fancy and I'm not going to
be editing so if I make a mistake put up
with it but I've just got off literally
with a sauce that I speak to regularly
and they've told me that the Studios
have agreed between themselves that
there is a deadline for all of these
strikes that there is a point at which
they do not want to go beyond and that
date is the 1st of November that they've
agreed between themselves again that
they need to get back to work before
Christmas and that they will concede
more as that date becomes closer now
deadline is reporting the conversations
between the writer's Guild and the
studios went very very well yesterday
and I can tell you that according to my
source that's because the Studios have
begunned that process of conceding a
little bit more they're hoping now that
the writers have been out of work long
enough that they're going to meet them
halfway and they can get a deal that
both sides can live with
but internally and very privately the
Studios have agreed that this November
first date is as far as they're willing
to go and they need to get back to work
after that so how does this affect
Stargate well speaking to somebody that
I know that works in public relations
um in and around Amazon they were asking
basically what projects are coming up
and what should their plans be so
they're looking forward to the next 12
months so if the Stargate movie is
coming out when and what preparation
should they be making when should they
start advertising when should they start
getting like putting interviews together
to build up a bit of excitement etc etc
they're basically trying to put their
calendar together that includes RoboCop
that includes a couple of other projects
that MGM and Amazon are doing
they were expecting to be told that the
penciled in date of spring 2025 uh well
actually it's late winter or spring so
2024 to Spring 2025 there is always a
bit of a window with these things
that's when they're expecting and that's
when the Stargate movie that is
supposedly planned is currently penciled
in for
PR were expecting to be told that date
would be pushed back they were expecting
to be told it'll be eight months from 18
months I should say from when the
strikes end but they weren't they were
told that those dates are still accurate
that is when we're planning these movies
to come out
so the pr people were a little bit
surprised by that they sort of
questioned it and they were told no
the dates are solid
so that confused them a little bit it
confused me a little bit
but it would seem that the states are
solid because Amazon do have an
expectation that they're going to be
able to get back to work by Christmas
they do expect the strikes Etc to have
ended by then and it's because there's
this internal agreement with them now
obviously the wga and the actors Union
could still continue to make that
difficult but basically the Studios have
that as a deadline internally and they
will if they get to that point pretty
much give the writers or the actors
whatever they want to end the strikes so
they know over Amazon that filming will
be able to start roughly around
Christmas for the Stargate movie
potentially for robocopper now that
might be a bit later because there's a
lot of work still to be done on
robocopters my understanding
but they know that's when they're going
to be able to go back to work so that's
how they know that their plan for these
releases isn't changing
so that's where we're at right now let's
see what the next couple of weeks brings
us because you know November 1st is what
five six weeks away that is going to be
really interesting to see what happens
so please get into the comments guys
tell me what you think does this sort of
make sense are these rumors starting to
come together are you excited about the
movie now it started to get a little
closer or is it still why are they doing
a movie I'd love to know get to the
comments if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you never miss any of our new videos and
I will continue to get the information
to you as quickly as humanly possible
even if that means I have to do Quick
videos like this before I start work
obviously I should have started 20
minutes ago but never mind
thanks very much guys see you soon and
stay safe